[Music]
when you hammer and iron nails you apply
force on the flat side of the nail the
pointed side of the nail which is in
contact with the wall then applies the
force on the wall and tries to pierce it
now let me ask you an interesting
question what will happen if you hammer
the pointed side and try to pierce the
flat side of the nail you will find it
difficult to push the flat face of the
nail through the wall even if you apply
more force than you did in the first
case what is the reason for this the
reason is that the pressure applied by
the tip of the nail on the wall is more
than the pressure applied by the nails
flat surface but the question is why
first notice that the area of the tip of
the nail is very less as compared to the
area of a flat surface this tells us
that the area of the surface on which
the force is applied matters we will
understand this in detail but first let
us define pressure we define pressure as
the perpendicular force acting on the
surface of an object per unit area on
which is acting it's easy force acting
per unit area we already know that the
SI unit of force is Newton denoted by N
and that what the area is meter squared
so the SI unit of pressure is Newton per
meter squared it is also called Pascal
which is denoted by PA why is it called
Pascal it was given the same to all of
the achievements of a French scientist
named Blaise Pascal for his
contributions in hydrostatics and
hydrodynamics observe the equation
carefully area is in the denominator of
the fraction what is this area well this
area is nothing but the area on which
force is applied say I keep the force
constant and I keep increasing this area
what will happen to the pressure will
the pressure increase or decrease use
pure mathematical logic you are today
if I have a fraction and I'll keep the
term in the numerator constant and keep
increasing the term in the denominator
then will the fraction increase or
decrease surely it will decrease so the
pressure will decrease if I increase the
area while keeping the force constant
with this newfound knowledge let's go
back to the example we saw earlier the
nails under wall notice that we are also
applying the force perpendicular to the
surface of the wall the angle between
the nail and the wall is ninety degrees
and not anything else if you notice the
tip of the nail has a very small area
compared to the flat surface of the nail
and hence the area of contact with the
wall reduces to great extent in the
first case hence the pressure applied by
the tip on the wall is greater than the
pressure applied by the flat surface
that is why it is easy for the tip of
the nails to penetrate through the wall
you can even use drill machines to drill
the hole into the wall you see that it
has two pointed tips for the same reason
you can easily cut the vegetables using
the cutting edge of the knife but if you
use the blunt edge of the knife it will
be difficult to penetrate it in what is
the reason in this case well in the
first sight the two edges might look the
same to us but if you look at them
carefully the cutting edge has small
triangle like shapes which shop outer
points the other edge has nothing of
these so if you cut a vegetable with the
cutting edge the area of contact between
the vegetable and the knife is greatly
reduced hence more pressure is applied
on the vegetables using cutting edge of
the knife and we are used to cut the
trees also have sharp cutting edges
instead of Placid ones it increases the
pressure on the tree due to the less
area of contact the examples that we've
seen so far are applications of high
pressure it's about how high pressure is
useful to us in some cases but it is not
always the case
the last situations
where we require low pressure let us see
some applications or advantages of low
pressure we use snowshoes to walk on
snow the reason for that is simple
due to the larger area in contact with
the snow snowshoes reduces the pressure
on the snow we are able to walk on it
without our feet sinking deep inside in
case of normal shoes due to
comparatively smaller area of contact
the pressure on snow is more and it
sinks our feet deep inside note that a
force applied on the snow in both the
cases is the same this force is nothing
but our weight on the snow have you ever
wondered why the wheels of an army tank
run on the steel tracks rather on the
ground
notice that the wheels are on steel
tracks and are not touching the ground
the army tank is huge in size if the
wheels run on ground due to less contact
area with the ground the pressure on the
ground will be massive however the
tracks have much larger area of contact
with the ground and hence the pressure
on the ground is reduced to a great
extent in all the examples that we have
seen in this video it is the solid which
is applying pressure on another solid to
liquids also apply pressure we will see
that in the next video
[Music]